hey 42 here once upon a time in a land
far far away
well Africa there lived a group of odd
looking standi-uppy creatures called
homo sapiens
early humans had been living in Africa
for hundreds of thousands of years
chasing gazelles and running away from
Lions but Homo sapiens was a little bit
different
if Homo neanderthalensis was stocky and
Homo erectus was cocky then Homo sapiens
was simply the sappiest Simeon on the
Savannah technologically Innovative
highly adaptable uncapable of organizing
into complex social structures when Homo
sapiens decided to up and leave Africa
about seventy thousand years ago the
species was taking steps that would
change the world forever in just a few
Deca Millennia these dauntless Drifters
discovered every nook of the Earth from
siberia's shivering Tundras to
Australia's arid expanses from America's
Grand grasslands to The Verdant valleys
of Asia
during that time they or should I say we
also learned to fly built cities
explored the solar system harnessed the
power of the atom and invented the
sandwich but all that progress has come
at a price today we're arguably in
danger of outgrowing our home planet
which has us wondering whether it's time
for the next great grand human migration
magic spoon is cereal reinvented their
variety pack comes with four
mouth-watering flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and my absolute favorite peanut
butter trust me these flavors will take
you straight back to your childhood but
without all the sugar instead magic
spoon brings you a delicious fueling and
nutritious cereal that's perfect for any
time of the day now let me tell you
about the nutritional values of magic
spoon because the numbers are impressive
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and four to five net grams of
carbs in each serving plus it's only 140
calories per serving did I mention it's
also keto friendly gluten-free grain
free and soy free for me magic spoon is
a game changer I don't have time in the
morning to prepare a breakfast from
scratch so magic spoon has become my
go-to recently I just know with magic
spoon I can keep to my personal health
goals one of which is to include more
protein into my breakfast so it just
works so well for me click the link
below to grab a variety pack and try it
today and be sure to use the promo code
42 at checkout to get five dollars off
any order or go to magicspoon.com 42 and
magicspoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee if you don't like it for any
reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked so click the link below
and use the code 42 for five dollars off
or go to magicspoon.com 42 and save five
dollars today a big thanks to Magic
spoon for sponsoring this video
now if you think messing up a planet
then boogering off is a bit like farting
in a lift and running away then you'd be
right but let's not get lost in ethical
debates instead we need to figure out
where the hell we're going
the spawn money sees Mars and they say
smart money because Elon Musk is both
smart and has lots of money and Ma seems
to be where he's off to but is he right
could human beings really travel to and
eventually colonize the red planet
Mars is a particularly appealing option
for human migration for several reasons
for starters it's one of the closest
planets to Earth of an average distance
of 140 million miles
it also has similar length days to Earth
so even though it only receives about 44
of the sunlight at least you won't need
to change your alarm clock
Mars is also rich in useful elements
like magnesium silicon and of course
iron which puts the red into the red
planet important resources like these
could all be mined when we get there
reducing the amount of expensive excess
luggage we'd need to book on spacex's
Starship
finally and most importantly Mars lies
on the cusp of our Solar System's
habitable zone the area around the Sun
in which liquid water could exist on an
orbiting planet's surface water once
flowed freely on the red planet and we
know that plenty of quality H2O can
still be found in its ice caps if we
found a way to melt them we could create
a life-giving Ocean between 5 and 11
meters deep across most of the planet
unfortunately the good news ends there
and the bad news is well really
bad with surface air pressure about one
percent of our own Mars has all the
atmosphere of a kebab shop on a Tuesday
Morning liquid water would boil away in
seconds just like your blood if you dare
to step outside without protection so
yeah don't do that
the measly Martian atmosphere isn't just
thin it's also 95 carbon dioxide which
is deadly to humans in high doses and
ironically a major reason why we might
be heading to Mars in the first place
Earth's thick atmosphere and strong
magnetic field Shield us from dangerous
Cosmic and solar radiation Mars has no
magnetic field and without those twin
Shields the Martian surface is a very
dangerous place indeed with levels of
ionizing radiation 40 to 50 times higher
than on Earth that's enough to
dramatically increase the risk of cancer
and can potentially cause acute
radiation sickness or even death Mars is
also home to some extreme weather dust
storms with winds hitting 250 miles per
hour can last for days or weeks and can
occasionally engulf the entire planet
they would pose a serious threat to
equipment spacesuits and our makeshift
Martian shelters but wait there's more
bad news Martian's gravity is only a
third of Earth's and we don't know
exactly what long-term effects that
would have on the human body but
astronauts who spent significant time in
space have suffered from muscle atrophy
and loss of bone density even in a
protective suit living on Mars might
Fast Track you to having a 90 year old's
body and Mars is cold I mean really cold
think minus 62 degrees on average and
minus 140 degrees on a nippy Winter's
day
oh and just in case you're the hungry
type I should probably mention that
Martian soil is toxic so we won't be
able to safely grow any food not even
Mars Bars lastly let's talk about social
Logistics colonizing Mars would be like
an eternal Christmas with the in-laws
and such experiences have taught us that
confined spaces and clutching
personalities can lead to depression
anxiety and a rage of homicidal thoughts
[Music]
so the basic summary here is that Mars
hates us and wants us all dead
the question is what can we do about it
well if there's one thing I learned
during my previous career as the
dictator of a small insular state is
that there's nothing nuclear weapons
can't fix oddly enough Elon Musk seems
to agree because he wants to make Mars
more habitable by bombarding it with 10
000 nukes but there is some method to
The Madness of declaring nuclear war on
an uninhabited planet
the dream scenario when it comes to
migrating to Mars would be to terraform
it that is using Tech to make it
habitable first we need to warm things
up a bit hence World War III Mars
Edition
musk plans to aim his Atomic Arsenal at
Mars's polar ice caps vaporizing the
large quantities of water and carbon
dioxide trapped within releasing these
greenhouse gases could theoretically
create a runaway greenhouse effect
warming Mars to Earth-like temperatures
unfortunately this bold plant has some
big issues for one thing Bond villains
aside it's actually quite tricky for
private individuals to acquire nukes
sorry Elon more importantly a 2018 study
concluded that nuking Mars while it's
kinda cool could trigger a nuclear
winter with dust and debris blocking out
what meager sunlight the planet
currently receives making it even colder
another idea would be to melt Mars's ice
caps not with bombs but with a mirror
the idea would be to stick a giant
aluminum mirror in orbit around Mars
concentrating sunlight on the southern
ice cap
the Innovative approach but it too has
drawbacks to focus enough energy to melt
all that ice the mirror would need to be
250 kilometers across that's about 20
bigger than Denmark
obviously we wouldn't be able to launch
aluminum Denmark into space from Earth
so we need to build this monstrous
mirror in orbit and considering the
International Space Station at a
staggering 94 meters across is our
largest man-made space object to date
it's clear we're not quite there yet
so directly melting Mars's ice caps
seems tough but maybe we could do it
indirectly by borrowing some lessons
from our own planet's past in the late
1980s chlorofluorocarbons better known
as CFCs were banned worldwide because
they were destroying the ozone layer but
it turns out CFCs are also incredibly
effective greenhouse gases ten thousand
times as potent as CO2 here on Earth
We're terrified of them but on Mars CFCs
might be our new BFFs we may even find
the raw materials to produce them in
Martian rocks and if we don't there's
always the Elon Musk friendly option of
crashing thousands of spaceships loaded
with compressed CFCs into Mars either
way pack Mars's atmosphere with enough
CFCs and we'd trigger a runaway
greenhouse effect sufficiently warming
the planets to release the CO2 stored in
the ice caps warming it even further
while simultaneously thickening Mars's
weedy atmosphere
okay so Mars is now warm enough for
flip-flops and shorts and the atmosphere
is thick enough that your blood won't
boil every time you pop to the corner
shop for a newspaper lovely and the
beefed up atmosphere means extra
protection from solar wind and Cosmic
radiation which we could boost even
further by generating an artificial
magnetosphere around the entire planet
scientists have come up with several
ways you might do that including
building a giant superconducting ring
around Mars equator or installing a
magnetic Shield between the Sun and Mars
great though this new Martian atmosphere
would be we shouldn't forget the minor
problem that it would be almost entirely
lacking in oxygen and therefore totally
unbreathable NASA's perseverance Rover
has already successfully converted
Martian CO2 into oxygen right there on
the surface using a device called Moxie
but scaling that up to an entire planet
might not be possible
another option would be unleashing
oxygen-producing microorganisms to
slowly increase O2 levels it might sound
far-fetched but that's exactly what
happened right here on Earth about 2.5
billion years ago when cyanobacteria
turned r1's methane and ammonia-rich
atmosphere into the tasty oxygen-rich
version that keeps us alive today
as surface conditions slowly improve we
can introduce a few Hardy plant species
to convert even more CO2 into O2 first
we'll need to detox the soil but NASA
has already grown healthy plants in
simulated Martian soil so it's
theoretically possible but merely upping
the oxygen levels wouldn't be enough
Earth's atmosphere is 78 nitrogen an
element that is inconveniently scarce on
Mars so to make Mars breathable we'd
have to import nitrogen on a massive
scale
one way to do that would be to round up
numerous nitrogen-rich asteroids and
just crash them into Mars
but a more grown-up approach would be
venturing to Saturn's largest moon Titan
which boasts a 95 nitrogen-rich
atmosphere admittedly shipping several
trillion tons of liquefied nitrogen from
Titan to Mars wouldn't exactly be a
cakewalk but if we're honest that's
pretty much been the theme of this
entire video
terraforming Mars is certainly possible
it's just going to be really really
difficult so difficult that NASA
scientist Chris McKay thinks it'll take
a cool 100
000 years
but we don't necessarily have to
terraform Mars to live there we could go
for a slightly more ambitious approach
and simply build artificial habitats on
or possibly beneath the Mars and surface
sure it's a tall order but it seems
solvable in the coming decades in fact
Elon Musk yeah him again already has
plans to build a fully functioning Mar
City with up to a million inhabitants by
2050. that guy really needs a hobby
the minor drawback to this particular
mad musk plan is to cost at roughly 10
trillion dollars that's around 10
percent of the GDP of every country on
Earth put together
so could humans really migrate to Mars
the answer is absolutely as for whether
or not we actually will before we blow
ourselves up die from a pandemic get
vaporized by a giant asteroid or super
volcano lose the war with robots get
enslaved by aliens or accidentally
starve to death whilst hanging out in a
VR World hopefully one where people have
found legs
your guess is as good as mine
thanks for watching